a man has been part of CBS sports
college basketball analysis since 2003
it's been quite some time for Seth Davis
how are you Seth yeah I can't believe
that this is my 16th tournament bbs is
that why is that why it's America's most
watched Network I've been wondering okay
dad and Madam Secretary you and Madam
Secretary
okay so when I put when I first got
there they used to call me the dream job
with hey look we yeah I feel the same
way Zion returning tonight what what are
you hearing about that any minutes
restrictions what are you what are you
hearing about with this there are no
restrictions on him as far as I know I
think he's been healthy for a while to
be honest rich you know that last game
at North Carolina if that was an NCAA
Tournament games a Sacramento sweet 16
game there's no doubt that he would have
played so it's that the knee is fine
it's a matter of him being in game shape
at this point and that's really hard to
throw a guy like that into the mix oh no
about half services of an effort and
energy if he's not really in in full
condition so you know certainly smart to
have an abundance of caution he'll have
you know probably a couple of games you
know theoretically maybe three games in
the ACC tournament to get into shape and
in another two days of practice to get
ready for the NCAA are in your
experience of covering this sport Seth
Davis will there be a more scrutinized
shoe in the history of the sport than
the one that he laces up to his left
foot I actually poked around and no one
will answer this question shockingly
enough I'd like to know where that shoe
is somebody had to save that shoe I mean
at the very least you should be all
candor auctioned off for charity may be
signed by Barack Obama who's a few feet
away you know I think was interesting
riches I've heard coaches kind of
complain to me about how light these
shoes are that was the first thing I
thought of because for the general
public you know the public likes walking
around in light shoes but they also less
support so I don't know what the data
would back it up but I know coaches
believe that it's not just Nike by the
way they're all kind of competing for
that that you're seeing more foot into
injuries and ankle
the reason stress fractures and stress
reactions because of that well I would I
would think for sure that you had to be
sent back to some sort of laboratory in
Oregon they I'm sure they wanted to test
that etc or make sure it's removed from
public circulation a and and B you know
they will Charles Barkley went on on on
TNT but while going out and fully saying
that he is a Nike guy that he heard that
it's the same shoe that that design had
been wearing all year long and that he
was a type of guy that he would change
shoes almost every game is what Charles
said back when you play you know I don't
know I that struck me because I hope
people have said that I don't know that
do Corzine have ever confirmed that
they're kind of the flagship Nike
program so I don't want to talk about it
but you know that would be something
that would be good there's no and when
you talk to other I work with a lot of
NBA guys on television and a lot of them
will say that they've done that so it
wasn't so exceptional but given the
circumstances and given design you know
Zion just seems like a cartoon character
you know so the fact that it was him and
the Carolina game that Obama was there
and everybody was watching him very
first minute of the game and then he got
hurt because of it and not once the
whole debate about whether he should
shut it down I mean it was a pretty
pretty epic moment Seth Davis here on
the Rich Eisen show and I'm just glad
that that hole shut it down argument is
is a moot one right now I you know and I
know Charles also said he was the voice
that said that players play do you think
at all that that was a realistic
conversation that was going on and do it
was it was you know what on the one hand
it was one of the dummer say I mean look
at today's media culture media climate
social media is hard to keep lowering
that bar on the surface but I'll say
this rich I actually thought it was a
pretty healthy discussion because it
made people really think about well what
is everyone talked about what the
players are doing for the school and all
the money they generate but is really
much discuss about what they're getting
out of it even under the current system
flawed as it is and I think what people
step back and like I mean who among us
wouldn't trade places I'm Lansing right
now I mean look at the life that he's
living and what injury could he possibly
suffer that's going to keep him
being the number-one player in the draft
and having every chance at a lucrative
NBA career he's playing for Duke
University on a great team that has a
chance to win the national championship
with his best friends and you know being
on a campus and being a man environment
and being the focus of everybody's
attention who among us wouldn't trade
places with him right now so I actually
thought on balance it was a pretty
healthy discussion because it may force
people to focus on what Zion Zion is
exploiting the system to his benefit
Seth Davis here on the Rich Eisen show
okay so conference tournaments beginning
in earnest what what could actually
change seating significantly in inaction
over the next several days Seth you know
I guess bullet pointed for me yeah well
big I always find the bubble aspect of
it to be far more interesting that who's
going to be number one side like that I
love to talk the conversation on number
one seats because anything that gets
people interested it mean it's great for
the sport but I think it's one of the
most overblown things in sports and what
really is the difference between being a
one-seater of to see well in terms of
that is because it seems that the
selection committee has been under
seating some considerably tough
conference small supposedly small
conference champions or the difference
between a 3 and a 4 means you know maybe
taking on Murray State potentially you
know yeah I want no part of seeing this
kid Marant the way that he's playing but
uh not to interrupt you so I guess who's
who's on the bubble that needs to win
this week you think yeah that's like
that to me like we talked about the
mid-majors that's going to be another
point of discussion what are we talking
about all week as well I think Belmont
is this year's call celebra in in that
regard but you know right now I'm I'm
watching it's halftime of Ohio state of
Indiana and both those teams are well
under 500 in their conference which to
me you know I realize it's kind of
unrealistic but I think if you're under
500 and league play you should be
ineligible for an at-large bid that
aside you know I think the loser of that
game is probably not going to be in
there might be room enough for political
but it's gonna be a lot harder and they
both know the hardest thing because the
committee has to do legite take into
account injuries like for Duke you know
lost a bunch of games without science
once one KML season at full strength and
that was back in November in Vatican
daga so you know both Indiana and Ohio
State have had injury issues and then
over in the ACC NC State is at halftime
of against Virginia right now and
actually winning I don't expect it to
hold up but if it does and state
probably has played its way into the
tournament so but people say that the
regular season doesn't matter in college
basketball I mean there are games that
were played in November and December
with those results really little marker
you're talking about teams that are so
close in terms of their resume one
really good win on November 11 is the
difference between being in the term and
not being in the tournament so a lot of
a lot of games being played today and
tomorrow are really front with with
gravitas if you will well what an the
holy heck happened the pac-12 man and
you could say that about all major
sports for sure but I mean yeah what in
the world is going on with the pac-12
you know it's I I caution people against
sort of cause and effect and in the case
of the pac-12 you have a little bit of a
perfect storm I think one thing that
happened is that its flagship program
really these days is Arizona and they
got hit by this FBI scandal which you
know really crushed their recruiting for
one cycle now they have a great class
coming in next year so this idea of
Miller's getting run out of town is not
quite accurate and then he also had us
feel they have a really bad year so it's
just the fact that those two teams alone
are experiencing down clinicals in the
court and USC was also caught up in the
FBI scandal but you know their situation
was more older players graduating so it
to me it's just these things go in
cycles and if you go if you go over the
years you've had I think every
conference has pretty much gone through
this rehab one year oh my god like
they're the best and everyone's getting
in and then you know five years later
it's it's as bad as they've ever been
back 12 has Pat look in terms of what's
going on with football and a lot of
other things and you know they are
always kind of going to be at a
disadvantage in terms of the television
exposure and the petrol workers out a
lot of challenges okay but in a
different time zone so
but I would I wouldn't hold a bake sale
farm for too long I think at a local ab
right now and I think that pretty soon
they'll be on an upward cycle and
everybody will talk about hey the
factual is back yeah I mean the Pacific
time zone teams are Gonzaga up there in
Eastern Washington and Nevada I mean
that that's it pretty much you know you
know what let me say this there's mark
you always gets mad at me when I call
Gonzaga in the pager they are certainly
not a mid-major in terms of how they
operate and what they do and how they
went but I think we just taken zaga I
mean it as a compliment I mean look what
they've done they were in the national
championship game one possession away
from laying the whole thing two years
ago and they've lost everybody pretty
much on that team that guys are on that
team for role players now starters but
they bring in every other's Gonzaga
there's no West Coast Conference in the
middle of Spokane Washington and Endor
he's gonna be a 1 or a 2 season and a
favorite to win it all again it's
incredible
with that university that community and
of course with their coach it does all
right so give me your prediction on the
1 seeds except before I let you go off
to New York to do the show well I would
say at the your starting point is you're
gonna have two ACC teams at minimum not
out of the question
there could end up being three ACC teams
but certainly between Virginia North
Carolina and Duke two of those three
will be there I think Kentucky or
Tennessee if they win the SEC Tournament
will lock up another 1 seed the fourth
spot right now I would get to Gonzaga
but I think the inside track belongs to
Michigan State the way they finish the
year again they had injury issues or
getting a guy back if they win a big 10
tournament they've got more what we say
quadrant one wins and any team in the
country if they win the Big Ten
tournament they won the Big Ten regular
season they suffered some losses with
injuries getting healthy I think they
end up on the web in which case good
Zagal would be your number Oh
overall top to C but either way they're
going to be sent out west
so for Gonzaga it's not a huge
difference between them one of the two
is just plain 216 verses 15 of the first
round all right Seth thanks for the call
um safe flight safe journey we'll chat
with you during the tournament itself
next time we chat they'll be actually
dancing they'll be dancing
fantasy on which thank you I appreciate
that Seth thanks for coming on that's at
Seth Davis hoops on Twitter set
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience